i can solve the cube can you it's
actually quite easy the first step is
we're going to create a daisy
you can really call it whatever you want
i'm going to call it the get out of my
business
now we're going to match up these top
edges and put them to the bottom
duh now we need to solve this entire
bottom layer it's so easy that even like
a child could do it
sometimes i just say words and they form
sentences and they make sense the bottom
solved
now i'm going to solve the middle this
is not a speed cube middle layer
done now i need to get a yellow cross up
here this cube is so
freaking slow turn and i turn and it
doesn't happen okay it happened
we've got to match up all of these
crosses to have the same color i do a
couple more algorithms
just let me live my best life and there
we have it
the crosses are now complete we gotta
match the corners now
ugh don't want to be bothered but here
we are i'm being bothered corners match
great this is where
we just complete the cube this is how
we do it it's not even a friday night
and here we are
done call me